[Music]
wait a second raya the warrior is here
but she almost faced a much much darker
ending in the film
raya and the last dragon hit us in all
the right field spots
but knowing that certain characters
almost didn't return has us completely
rethinking what the movie could have
been
my girl ryan and i are gonna fix the
world bring everyone back
had disney chosen to go with their much
darker alternate ending
sisu truly would have been the last
dragon in the ending
we saw sisu and all her dragon siblings
return but it turns out that there was a
potential we wouldn't see any of the
dragons ever again
the reason they considered this ending
is that it would have reinforced the
idea that sisu couldn't just sweep in
and solve all the problems
it was up to people trusting each other
and working together to overcome
hardship
considering that reasoning we can
understand how impactful a message the
alternate ending would have given
the debate was a long and tough one as
the creators didn't want to forego the
message they wanted to reach audiences
but in the end they decided they wanted
to bring a happy ending to the screen
the mystical ending we see in the movie
is actually more authentic from a
cultural perspective
we're so glad they chose to embrace that
both out of respect for the cultural
ethos as well as the fact that it would
have been
heartbreaking to lose sisu forever well
compliments to the chef
we loved seeing elsa's portrayal of the
fifth dragon oh
wait we meant sisu sisu is the fifth
dragon
elsa is the fifth spirit of course
though
that's not all the two films have in
common remember that dark alternate
ending we were just talking about
well the alternate ending from frozen
two was eerily similar
elsa who also looks extremely similar to
sisu
for a dragon and a human anyway nearly
passed away forever as well
the endings the creators wound up going
with fortunately involved happier
outcomes with the two beloved characters
returning to life unscathed
even the way they're brought back is
similar thanks to her dragon siblings
sisu ends up being resurrected
fortunately for the disney world
siblings never fail to rescue as anna
did the same for elsa and frozen too
remember when everyone was turned into a
statue in ryan the last dragon
well also knows how they feel since of
course she spent some time as a frozen
statue herself
on a bit of a happier note the
commonalities between elsa and sisu's
water-based powers are
unmistakable that blue glow this this is
my little sister amba's magic
i got the glow yeah we've seen that
before
how about those graceful moves across
water pads and seemingly
effortless soaring sisu has some
seriously strong elsa vibes there's no
denying it
my big brother pangus magic
there was one other pretty significant
similarity between frozen two and ryan
the last dragon
and that was the question of raya and
elsa's sexuality
there was strong speculation that elsa
was meant to be queer
though the confirmation of this theory
we hope to get frozen too never came to
pass
the idea that raya is queer and has
feelings for namari
is definitely floating in our minds if
there is a sequel
fingers crossed then disney has another
shot to bring the first
openly queer character to the screen
this would be a huge step for the disney
franchise and brought a representation
of the society we actually live in
we're not the only ones rooting for this
coupling though the voice of raya kelly
marie tran has expressed her excitement
over
the speculations from audiences since
she herself thought the same doing the
film
and was rooting for them trans said she
loved their relationship and hopes that
if there is a sequel
we'll get to see their relationship
really blossom thank you debwa
you've been very helpful
we're already thinking of their couple
names what will they be
nemaya rayari either way we're rooting
for them
there is one other detail that makes us
believe there really could be something
more between rai and namari
and that's the fact that the scene that
was rewritten the most was the meeting
scene between the two when they were
young
since their reconciliation at the end is
so crucial their meeting had to have
just the right feeling
the many rewrites tried to create the
most authentic vulnerable and delicate
scene they could
this kind of effort wouldn't be put in
if the relationship wasn't so
significant
who knows maybe one of the versions
included a stronger inkling of romance
all the indicators are there and with
the wild success of raya and the last
dragon
we might just see a defining romance
come to the screen in a sequel
our fingers are crossed for team nemaya
or team rayari
either works well we're definitely glad
they stuck with the ending they did
and going with the same team that did
the music for frozen 2 was a great call
now we're really just hoping we'll get
to see namari and raya reunited in a
sequel so we can see their relationship
blossom
disney has a shot to do something
amazing don't let us down